eerie new interview with will smith
there's a person you want to be viewed
as and then there's who you
really are
during an episode of david letterman's
my next guest needs no introduction shot
before that infamous oscar slap keep
will reveal he saw a vision of his
career collapse after ingesting the
hallucinogenic drink ayahuasca all of a
sudden it's it's like
i start seeing all of my money flying
away and my career my whole life is
getting destroyed so this is your fear
this is my feeling
and i'm in there i'm
wanting to vomit and all of that and i
hear a voice saying this is what it is
in another moment that has not aged well
post oscars will give david tips on how
to fight show me that
but don't hit me so he drops his right
he drops his right foot back and that's
how you know that he's preparing to
sneak the shot oh wow
and then
okay right your right hand right back
that was frightening don't do that again
meanwhile e.t has a first look at
tomorrow's new red table talk episode
where jada gives telling insight into
what she seeks in relationships my thing
was just not having protection yeah
that's my
biggest wound that comes out
in all my relationships those women that
you see and you think are so strong
there's this terrified little girl
underneath mm-hmm yeah that's me
[Music]